so how did you find uh G Bracken Man
actually we from the same area I'm from
77th Street he from 84th Street though
you know but all blocks is the same we
out the swans um I've been knowing bro
for a while um I've been seeing him rap
for a while but I never wanted to be
that person who like oh yeah I'm a sign
I'mma put on my Young Homie or young
[__] from my hood to make sure like bro
that [__] corny like I care about music
and I care about art and I saw this
young [__] actually care about his
music and care about art when I opened
my studio two years ago um I opened the
doors up to like five or six of the my
young homies or not even my young homies
my homies from my hood um and told him
look bro I got a studio the doors open
if we ain't booked come record you can
come record any day I got four rooms I
know all four ain't going to be booked
every day all you got to do is bring
your own in I you a free room bring
engineer but this [__] he record
himself he shoot videos he edit videos
art he does anything digital anything
you ask him to do for his own career he
can do it so you're saving a lot of
money hell yeah not just saving a lot of
money he understands a lot of money he
he understands himself as a brand and if
you can't get his brand right he'll
figure out how he figure out his own
brand right and that made me [__] with
bro a lot more you're editing your own
videos and stuff if the editor don't get
it right my own video every time I mean
not every time look that's so important
though cuz like name one video I got out
that I didn't edit but you had an editor
but you you added to the editor I edited
he technically edited I bet you got that
on the credit I just let's give gutter
his Ro it's important cuz you know reals
and YouTube shorts and all this [__] is
so important it's like if you if you
don't know how to edit your own [__]
like that then you're [__] way behind
exactly if you got to wait for another
person to send you a little reel for
your IG or your your [__] your
YouTube short then like bro what are you
doing like hello there's no excuses
either I know I at first though I didn't
know how to work Tik to or none of that
[__] I used to be on my ass like bro
that's some [__] you really got to get
into because if you don't do that [__]
like you you're not going to follow with
the algorithm on me so I had to get into
that [__] too that [__] was crazy like
it's important man it's it's like it
people I think people used to fight Tik
Tok cuz it came off like a corny thing
to do yeah but now it's like you got to
if you get it it's great same thing
YouTube shorts and reals it's all the
same [__] bro it's all I mean you just
got to get into that algorithm and keep
putting shots up fact for sure so what
do you uh obviously you got music out I
mean I've been I've seen a lot of your
[__] I was just talking to the homie
about you me and head were talking about
you like three or four weeks ago we're
just talking about like new La guys um
what G give me kind of like what you got
going on right now uh right now I'm
working on a project well my project I
just finished my project but like that
[__] crazy I was working on that [__]
for like a whole year like that was my
first time working on the project that
long um it got the baby Stone gorillas
on it and it got earol suy rip uh it got
other features but I don't want to say
no names it got big features probably
how big big big yeah like a big like big
Bank big not big Bank big after that I
got featur big Bank big
probably um can he just cuz cuz you
could he just get the Y feature for free
yeah but like it's about timing it's
about timing you don't want to get it
just to get it you got to get it when
it's
right that's what I told myself too
though like I don't I'm I'm not the type
of [__] that I know YG he know y so
it's like it's nothing y yo it's so
funny cuz I work with artists and
they're like be like hey man you you are
you know so and so I'm trying I'm like
bro what the [__] am I look like sending
you sending your record off to this you
want me to cash in that favor now or
when you got some real [__] going on me
you want you want the artist to [__]
with you like like on your own it's
going to happen on his own yeah not just
through a thing with me is about being
organic bro I ain't get this far because
I went to school I ain't get this far
because this or that bro I got this far
about being organic really trusting the
vision trusting my plan staying
dedicated and it's like those are the
things I'm trying to put back you got
Mazy on your project nah no okay I feel
you shouted out Mazy in the freestyle
that I Fu I [__] I [__] with Mazy yeah I
hard but it's also part about developing
an artist is like all right having an
artist who developing around artists who
made it or had somewhat of level of
success and having him be able to have
conversations in regular places with
them to understand versus just oh yeah
let's take a picture for the gram like
nah these is my homies going to come sit
at the studio like bro we had ASAP Ferg
came out here from New York came to hang
with me MH [__] we only talked for like
15 minutes he sat in the studio with
this [__] for like 3 hours listening to
his album listening to other records
talking to him about being an artist
talking to him about coming to New York
and it's like that's the type of [__]
that I want bro to get I don't want oh
yeah I'm cool with Ferg so Ferg hop on
this song nah it's going to happen
exactly yeah like I want the real [__]
so it's like when a fan see it and they
go do their research and go pay
attention like oh he deserved that not
just cuz he standing next to this ain't
no industry plant mhm I was going to ask
you like uh being a a there's there's a
lot of dope energy out of LA right now
yourself 310 baby we talked about got a
big record for sure zama's killing it
like who's uh uh like who are who are
some of the upcoming La artists that you
just really like you know Kudos I see
what you're doing I'm a fan like maybe y
end up working together is any anybody
who comes to mine yeah baby Stone
gorillas they're on your project they're
killing it who p on my project uh I got
I got records with all the baby song
Gorillas though um Wally the Sensei I
love W Sensei W is amazing crazy um big
S B big dope yo W is just like one
record away like like from like really
like he got a couple already but he's he
he's capable of just having a number
like yeah he's crazy yeah uh kayin asash
yeah Kaylin's great uh I [__] with as
bash hey kayin Somebody went lived in
Atlanta for a little bit yeah he told me
and built with all the DJs in Florida
Atlanta and all that yeah yeah bro like
it's like when I be looking at this [__]
like bro when somebody trying to become
president
right it for like two years straight
they going state to state city to City
shaking hands kissing babies doing all
this to be in your face so that you care
or you think that they care [__] you
got to treat your music the same way
like but when we first came like bro
when y went on tour with M Miller oh
yeah I remember oh I got a couple of Y
incidents to ask you about we probably
had one song world he was not allowed to
perform in Phoenix
though we not going to talk about oh we
I was there I hosted the concer listen